[Music]
so my story is a little bit different I
actually started as a machine learning
researcher and did that for quite some
years working in a lab in Israel doing
solving cybersecurity challenges with
machine learning was quite fascinating
and then I was hit with a really
fascinating project by IBM and they gave
me petabytes of data so back then we
didn't really have enough frameworks a
platform to analyze all this kind of
data we really had had to open a little
bit of MapReduce and mahute was
something that we just started with I
don't know if you any of you are
familiar with mahute has anyone ever
heard about yeah that's yeah yeah
probably that's a little bit ancient and
since then I realized okay data
engineering in this kind of world and
how do we take machine learning and
actually put them in production it's
quite fascinating so I moved to a
position of what back then was a
back-end software developer which is
today we call that data engineering and
I'm recently joined Microsoft a year ago
and I'm happy to say that this is the
right place for me to kind of close the
gap and say okay how do we do machine
learning how will you do data science
how do we take it to scale and how do we
think about ethical and responsible AI
while doing it
so before we gonna jump in is any of you
know about different problems we have
about bias nai are you familiar with the
story it's because I don't want to
bombard you with a lot of crazy stories
I'll just give you one in Israel in 2017
some years ago someone from the
philistine Ian region published a post
saying good morning it was a post in
Arabic and behind them there was a
bulldozer standing at the back so a
picture of him bulldozer and good
morning seems rational but the thing is
Facebook language translator translate
it to Allah walkabout and let's go kill
them something like that you can only
imagine what happens in Israel when
someone sees a picture like that with
this kind of phrase on Facebook everyone
is getting into alarm mode everyone is
running everyone is afraid everyone is
hiding no schools no ones go to the
office no nothing and that's all because
one algorithm got it wrong translating
Arabic words it had to option and it
took the wrong one yeah
so I'm sorry I have to open with that
but that's real life so here you go some
puppies
and I promise that's the last sad story
for today okay so let's start at the
beginning what happens when we get the
data for the first time what happens
when we face some business challenge and
we need to figure it out through data so
first of all we look at that we're
trying to understand what it means oh
and down there there's a live captioning
it's all but tricky it's still rendering
but you'll see that it catches different
words and there's also delay so
apologize for that okay so we'll look at
that we're trying to figure out what it
means and then we enter something called
the machine learning process machine
learning life cycle if someone here
already familiar with the machine
learning life cycle already doing it in
the day to day their job at the office
cool so how it looks like first we need
to gather the data we need to get all
the data that we need in order to solve
the problem the second phase will be the
feature extraction we need to understand
what features we need to use in order to
feed into our algorithms we need to
clean we need to normalize the data
there's the whole process around it then
we need to select the algorithms machine
learning is statistical based but then
again there's a lot of different
algorithms we can pick from according to
our business use cases the corridors a
challenge we want to figure out so we
need to select the algorithms and we
also need to evaluate the model so we
need to understand how we're evaluating
the model what kind of different
criterias we can run with and then we
need to do some data or inside
visualization but not that's just not
the first thing we're gonna do because
we're actually gonna do it in repeat
until we get a good results until we'll
get results that were happy with all
right yay we got the result we we have
it everything works well you know we try
the kögel a challenges someone here is
doing car goals once in a while in the
university college okay so cargo has a
really good challenges for data
engineers who want to start want to
understand different features definitely
if you're not doing it yet definitely go
go there and
it's a great place to learn new things
it's a great place to learn new
algorithms and new challenges but the
thing is the data there is kind of
already cleaned up mashed up like
already ready for us to kind of use so
that's great when you're doing projects
for university but the thing is that you
hate real life and then it doesn't work
but you had a goal you want to have high
accuracy and this thing in real life
just you know doesn't make it your boss
is gonna be mad your team lead is gonna
be mad you can make a project a product
out of it because you aim for high
accuracy that's not good enough
so what can you do you can automate all
the process because you already
understand you will probably need to run
it a few hundred times in order to get a
good result and how do you do it you do
it using pipelines but just a second
what are pipelines
what does that mean so pipelines are
mostly a sequential tasks that we can do
one after the other something that we
can automate and we can act when we can
change different stuff along the way but
you know we just need to press start and
it's gonna run again and again we might
change a little but we can move my
twittle over there machine learning
features there we might take a little
bit of the different features that we
extract after the data but the thing is
the whole process should be as automated
as we can so this is a simple
architecture of how you do machine
learning pipelines on big data at scale
so on the left you have some data that
you want to get into the system and it's
different kinds of data cuz we're doing
with big data it can be structured and
structured it comes from different
resources maybe Jason maybe CSV file
maybe forget maybe text who knows maybe
binary a lot of different kind of files
that we can get into the system and then
it all we need to ingest it somehow so
we can use event hub or Kafka or
different things and what it gives us it
actually gives us a distributed queue
and with a distributed queue we make
sure we're not losing any of the data
and we're actually gonna process each
and every one of them later on would
like to put it into
storage and after that we would like to
actually prep and train our Michigan
learning algorithm and one of the ways
to do it is using Apache spark and one
of the men that system we have on the
cloud for party spark is Azure data
bricks or any of you familiar with Azure
data bricks already cool are you working
with spark someone here works with spark
cool spark ml awesome
so Sparks gives us a lot of things that
we can work with and the data bricks is
the managed service of Apache spark that
you can actually just go click create a
workshop and start running with your
notebooks and later on you can connect
everything to something called Azure
machine learning you can do different
experience you can track everything you
do there and basically it gives us the
whole night's pipeline of how we can do
the same experiments again and again
just tweaking a little bit some of the
things so let's see a lot of how it
looks so here we can I'm gonna define
something called mo flow and Allen flow
it's also something comes from the data
breaks libraries so I'm a flow gives us
an environment to manage our experiments
so we can actually track everything and
put it into some file that we can save
it later here I'm going to call it some
pipeline experience you can see that an
experience name I'm going to create the
client of mo flow and I'm gonna start
doing some experience with it I have
some run variable that I'm defining
there and it's actually starting running
in the background
later on I would like to configure the
machine learning pipeline stages so
let's say I'm doing some simple work
over text so I need a tokenizer some
hashing function that I want to use and
some regression that I'm gonna use
something a regression function that I'm
going to use so I'm defining my
tokenizer you can see it at the
beginning later the hashing functions
and later the regressions the linear
regressions that I want to tap do they
want to work now I have all those three
instances ready
one quick thing you should notice that
I'm making sure that the input of the
output of each and every one of them
works together so if the tokenizer has
an input of text I need to make sure
that my data that goes there will have
the field of text same for the output
column if I'm using for the tokenizer
the output column name is words I need
to make sure that if I'm going to use
the hashing after that the input column
for the hashing should have the same
name as the output column so this is
where I'm using the tokenizer dot get
output column name it helps me make it
more consistent and later on I'm just
putting it all together apache spark
gives us a really nice library it's not
new but not a lot of people knows about
it it helps us put everything together
in one array and why don't we put it in
one array because it's sequential we
know our pipelines should happen one
after the other in a sequential manner
so we set the stages we said okay we're
gonna start with tokenizer
hashing and then the linear regression
so we can have the model and we're gonna
call fit and fit gonna gives us the
actual model that we can use later we
can save it we can write it two files
and later on we can load it if we need
so let's say I'm in data science I'm
working with some data engineers I can
create my model and then I can seven
into a file and the data engineer can
take it from there load it into their
system and actually start running it or
if I'm working with people that tests my
code it's the same so if I'm working
with the QA they can take it from there
and test it again and again again as
much as we need so this is just an
example of how I can load it back the
last line there so the stay model
loading it from the file okay
let's create some mock tests so this is
just a data frame spark data frame that
I'm creating yep we don't need this one
and then we take the model and we call
transform and transform actually works
on the data that I give that I'm saying
okay take this data and give me the
output and this is going to print the
prediction that we have there so I can
actually take this code put it in
production giving it the right model
that it needs and then it governs gonna
give me the prediction that I need in
real life close and save just to make
sure I'm closing my run under the Emma
flow so it looks nice it looks easy but
life is a little bit more challenging
than that
data engineer and data science have
different expectation big data project
are very different than cago
competitions and even minor tasks
they're required Python and Scala and
all this kind of skills that not
everyone has so I don't know if you ever
had the experience of sitting in the
room with that engineering and data
science and DevOps no one goes happy
after those conversations ever really
yeah so this is one of the challenges we
face so then we want to put everything
into a bigger context I mean we're not
finishing in just creating the machine
learning algorithm himself we want to
have it actually running in production
so this is where we need to be able to
serve that Marlowe and serving that
model we can do it in different ways we
need to store it and some in some place
some storage and then we need to have
apps at the end that are actually going
to make sure it's going to land into our
clients or we want to connect it to some
place where people can visualize the
output and visualize the insights to
some of the ways to do it is using power
bi which is a great visualization tool
all right we achieved high accuracy
we're great our team needs loves us we
get a high bonus everyone is happy but
wait a second what is the cost what is
the cost of high accuracy
false-positive I know sorry that's true
I said I'm not gonna make you sad but uh
yeah high accuracy sometimes we pay with
false positives and false positives mean
we classify wrong and what does it mean
classifying wrong when we're dealing
with humans when we're dealing with
humans classifying wrong sometimes means
sending people to jail sometimes mean
people are not gonna gonna be able to
apply for a specific job sometimes it
means these people are gonna live under
danger or stress for the rest of them
lives just because we classify them
wrong so I'm sorry here you go puppy
let's update our goals that we think
about how we do it so we need to know or
algorithms need to be love fall meaning
respecting all applicable laws and
regulations it needs to be ethical
respectable ethical principles and
values it needs to be from robust from
both technical perspective so we can
actually take it and work with it so we
have no goals it's not only accuracy
it's not only to get the best accurate
model we actually have more things we
need to think about and we need to work
with it but why is that a challenge it's
a challenge because machine learning is
a black box we get some data we put it
into the system we train the model and
we get the model the output and later on
we would do some prediction we do some
testing we take the data we fit it into
the model and we get the prediction back
it works at a black box most of the time
we don't really understand how it works
underneath and this is one of our
biggest challenges so let's say we take
this kind of architecture that we had
before
and we think about it what can we do
with it what can we do different first
we need to check in transform the data
better better we need to look for biases
we need to understand what exists there
second we need to visualize the model we
need a way to understand first of all
how our data is distributed and then how
are we going to visualize the model
better in order to create better models
so that takes a little bit of the
information but it kinda gives us a
great value and we're gonna do it using
something called explainers I'm gonna
look at soon but first thing first
is anyone here knows how Microsoft
support responsible AI so we do multiple
things and that's only a short list
first of all we provide you with online
free high quality courses you can take
and do from everywhere you want and
there's the thing right there second of
all we invested 1 billion dollars in
opening I open AI aims to create a
friendly and ethical AI so Microsoft
said okay we're gonna put money on the
table here you go third thing is we have
150 million dollars grants for groups
and students and heavy one who wants to
do AI for good so if you're doing
something like that and budget is the
thing check it out third thing is that
fourth thing and sorry we invest in
open-source so we created some
open-source tools for you so you can
actually take your model and explain it
and explore it and look at that and see
it and understand what it actually gonna
do and what it actually going to mean
and we call it machine learning
interpretability so this is the library
have and it split into three sections
we're gonna look at tabular data tax
data and image data tabular data and
deals with all the
machine learning trees and different
things around it and gives us a lot of
feature to explore those kind of data
text data helps us explore texts to make
sure we're getting the right algorithms
if we're doing an LP and all these kind
of works helps us make sure we exploring
we understand the relationship between
different words we understand we're
taking bias out of our algorithms and
then we have image data as how it how we
actually classify different images it
can be around crazy recognition it can
be around all this kind of stuff so here
we go a new set of tool for you to take
and start running with your models in
your day to day in the university on any
project that you do to start to get a
hint of what it means how is the machine
learning works behind the scenes so take
away the little bit the sense of a black
box and how do we do it this is a kind
of a short screenshot of how do we do it
with scikit-learn is any of you here
already try different sky kids learn
different cool so this is kind of a
short explanation about how you can do
it and on the bottom you can see how you
can import the importer of course you
need to install it and there's a lot of
adjustment and you need to work with
Python 3 and all this kind of stuff but
once you have it running you can start
using it and we're actually going to be
downstairs we have a booth so if you
want to try and you want to make it work
on your machines come say hi we'll help
you set it up but what it gives you it
gives you something called explainer and
the explainer help you visualize your
data better it shows you how the data
distributed what happens and what the
relationship between the different
features so you can start realized and
understand if you need more features you
don't need them are those features
biased the thing is it's not going to
tell you if it's biased or not it's up
to you so you still need to work with
data experts with domain experts with
business analysts to better understand
but here you have set of tools more
tools to make sure
you're creating a responsible AI and
this is just one of the things that you
can get out of it so you can actually
show you and visualize for you the data
in different areas so it takes the
features from visualization it's part of
it's part part of the edge or m/l studio
I'm not going to talk about it now
because it's a whole topic but you can
you can you should come downstairs to
the booth and we'll figure I'll make it
work for you okay so here's the villas
ation that can help us understand a
little bit more how it works and how we
work with it so we can understand the
relationship in the data and the
different kinds of features that we're
working it well maybe some features are
not relevant for us maybe we want to
bring more features in so it kind of
helped us a little bit start to work
with with what we have and this is for
you
this is the library so if you want to
take pictures and try it yourself and go
for it
this is a machine-learning
interpretability tool and there's a lot
of explanations tutorials step-by-step
how you set it up on different machines
how you set it up locally how you set it
up remotely if you work at the cloud you
can also work with it in the cloud it's
open source so you can work with it
anywhere you want based on sky could
learn it's also worked with Apache spark
data frames if you're curious and want
to do spark ml with Apache spark and
work with that basically everything that
implements the farm or if you have your
own models you need to implement predict
and predict populations and it's going
to give you it's going to work for you
but this is not it we also have
something called as your cognitive
services another cognitive services
actually it's a built-in API for AI so
you don't need to create your own models
and it has different areas that you can
work with there so it has face
recognition you basically give it a
picture and it will give you the
classification text and different LMP so
if you're doing sentiment analysis and
all this kind of stuff you can work with
it right out of the box all the other
stuff that you probably gonna need and
probably going to use so you don't have
to create your own models and what we do
behind the scene we do a lot of work to
make sure it's gonna be responsible
enough for you to start using it it's
not perfect
nothing is there's still a lot of
different false alarm stuff but
Microsoft is putting a lot of effort
into making sure this library gonna work
the right way without biases as much as
we can so if you wanna if you're looking
from some API out-of-the-box to start
doing and running machine learning AI
and you don't want to deal with the
heavy hassles of making sure it's not
biased making sure it works well at
scale and all this kind of stuff you can
use as your cognitive services cool
let's look how how it looks from data
bricks
so this is data bricks if you're not
familiar familiar with that this is a
Geo data bricks and I already set it up
for you so I need to do is the lounge
lounge the death desktop itself
and this is how it looks you can also
run it offline if you want on your local
machines as well here you have all these
different things that you can start
running with it without looking for it
here at the side you can look at recent
different things that I tried and play
with and also go to the communication
you can write code in Python our Scala
SQL or this kind of stuff you have the
data breaks guide really helpful and
also importing data so if you're using
your own data and you want and when you
want to start imported you can use it
from here I think the first thing you
want to do when you're using data breaks
is actually create the clusters
themselves go all the way back down here
you see those clusters and here you can
create your own cluster but already
create a few cluster for us so we have
this pipeline demos and stuff and you
can see I'm using different VMs and
there when you create the cluster it
asks you for the specific runtime that
you want to work with so I'm using the
6.0 the machine learning from runtime
just because I'm doing a lot of machine
learning and I'm going to be optimized
for me and it's also bringing me a lot
of different Python libraries and all
this kind of libraries that I won't need
to think about so it set up all the
arrivals behind the scenes but you can
do multiple stuff with it you don't have
to pick this way
under data it's gonna show me the
different data that we have or I can add
more here under here I can add more data
if I want some files other data sources
or whatever I want to work with if
you're familiar with spark you know that
sparks run jobs so here you can create
your own jobs or add them if you want to
add a jar or stuff like that you can
create them and schedule them to run at
the time that you want it also gives us
something called workspace where we can
actually go and dive into our different
notebooks and run them from there so you
can see we have different ones then
we're gonna look at this one so actually
here we're gonna collect some twits just
because it's fun hopefully the
Internet's working well looks good so we
define first of all need to define the
connection string because we want to
connect the event hubs and event hubs
implements cup Kafka api's so if you're
familiar with Kafka you know there's a
there's a producer and consumer so
you're just gonna set this one and here
you can see it waits to run
I'm gonna take it one at a time
oops okay I'm gonna stop it I'm gonna
run it one by one one by one just so it
will be easier for us so let's start
with this one all right so we created a
connection let's connect to gather
Twitter instance so you can actually
start and query Twitter to get wit
school
now we're gonna connect event hub and
Twitter data source querying hashtag
data
so you can actually see there are some
events some tweets coming up some people
have data meetings data management
solutions
some other native stuff Big Data cool
and now we want to read the streams so
let's turn this off let this run and
we're actually gonna get something in
binary and this is how it works with
Fatih Kafka it says it in binary and
that's something that we can't really
read so you can see it here the whole
body is in binaries okay so it's Park is
really easy to transform the data so
that's the first thing that you want to
take you want to transform the data and
how we did transform it we take the
incoming string and we just change it
we're casting and over with the columns
so this is how we do it with the Apache
spark API which column give me the name
what the feel that I'm reading it from
and what am i what am i doing to it so
I'm casting this one
okay so now I can actually look at the
text cool alright so I get the tweets
data something-something data cool but
this is fine but we say we want to
analyze those tweets right so we start
we're gonna use some cognitive services
yes cancel that so in order to use
cognitive services first we need to
configure some case classes to start
running it with so this is an example of
how we can configure the case classes
for sentiment analysis this is basically
data classes that will help us hold the
variable so we can use it later so this
is how it looks like and then we create
something called the sentiment detector
it's basically wrapping some JSON and
prettifying it will be easier for us to
work with it later
you can see here it takes the request
and coded the text and do other
manipulation on it and then how we
connect everything together we use UDF
do DF inspark is a user-defined
functions and actually enable us to do
different functionality over the data
frames that we work with so here's how
we connect everything together we
actually going to call the cognitive
services and the sentiment analysis from
our UDF's so to sentiment and UDF and
basically this is the one we're gonna
use and how we put everything together
this is how we do it with taking the
incoming stream that already live we're
filtering not null because we don't want
to have null in our data and now doesn't
mean anything for us we're casting the
body a string as we saw it already get
we get at binary so we're casting it to
string we call it content and then we
add this column saying sentiment and
here inside we're calling the function
sentiment that actually it's a UDF
functions wrapping our cognitive service
call
yeah and in the end this is what we're
gonna get we're gonna get the data frame
with a new column saying this is the
input that we got this is the sentiment
analysis and this is how how you make it
work with cognitive services all right
yeah so going back if you want to decide
and use your own machine learning
algorithms and create your own machine
learning algorithms that's great
make sure you're using explainers make
sure you understand the data make sure
you're creating a responsibility I
because at the end of the day our
algorithms and a product that we're
gonna create will only be good as the
data we're putting into the system so
this is something you should really
think about when you do that thank you
so much
here's a little of links for you to
start trying and playing with different
things there's still a lot of work to be
done in the area responsible AI and
explainers and creating different tools
and open-source is just the tip of the
iceberg it's just the beginning until we
can actually make it into something that
it automated and we can you know plug
and play definitely be aware if you're
creating machine learning algorithms be
aware of the different biases be aware
that you're dealing with humans lives
and it makes a lot of difference then
you know just classifying flowers so
hopefully you learn new stuff and thank
you
[Music]